we're looking at different categories of
questions that come under applications
of series and sequences right so it's
not just okay there's a turn and there's
a 50th 10 but what happens in between
all that theory stuff everything is
coming to the context and the primary
context you'll see is money okay that's
the query this is financial stuff okay
so yesterday we looked at time payments
today we're very briefly going to look
at superannuation now a big chunk a big
proportion of the questions you will do
that are applications of series and
sequences will be this exact thing or
some variants on that so to explain what
I mean let's just quickly get this down
now compound interest what is the
formula for compound interest starts
with a name P times okay very good
so this is simply key right you've got
some amount that you start with which we
call the principal right you have some
interest rate that gets applied that had
a ton repeatedly and then you do that
however many times now the way
competitors works is if you take your
money you pop it in the account and then
you don't touch it I guess we would call
that a term deposit right it's like
nobody in nobody out it just stays what
it is and it just faithfully adds its
interest on now what's superannuation
and all of its variants does is it takes
this and says well not only am I gonna
have that sum of money and it's going to
keep on adding interest not okay
but as time progresses I'm going to
insert more money in and each of those
will have its own interest calculations
applied to it
so being that you've got like the first
month's a bit of money and then the
second month and the third month and the
fourth month and each one it's growing
interest at its own rate
that's where the GP forms and that's why
this is the third thing so even though
not all of them will be explicitly
called superannuation such as this
question it's just going to deposit it
they won't function in the same
okay I'm putting money in its get
interest but I don't just do that I keep
on putting more okay now I'm picking up
I'm deliberately between up the examples
that are a bit kind of off-center right
but I just straight forward that they
just don't give you one two three and
then out jumps and hits which is very
straight forward I'm trying to pick out
once which I'm number one I don't have
been historically done poorly by haters
deep-sea students and number two it's
because they had like some curve boiling
so read this to me and you will see it
quite immediately right Joe opens the
making how it makes the initial deposit
so far so good at the start of each
subsequent month Joe makes a deposit no
mark this right we said okay you're
gonna put money in repeatedly and that's
pretty normal but here the amount that
she puts in each time it grows right so
it's not just that I keep on putting
money in but I'm putting in increasingly
large amounts okay now that's actually
not that surprising because if for
instance you have a normal salary job
and your income is increasing year to
year if was superannuation all the
government is doing is taking out a
percentage so a percentage is going to
grow maybe not this quickly maybe
inflation is really crazy in this
country that's why she's doing this okay
so you've got this
that man is growing but in addition to
that this is the normal part in addition
to that each part is gathering interest
right
so then we start at the questions right
almost always and in fact every example
I think I've found the pot one will give
you some kind of result that you have to
prove that's for two reasons number one
they want to see you can't just jump to
a formula right students who jump before
me they don't necessary understand what
is going on today and number two it's so
if you are still a bit confused to this
you can use it for the next class
so let's have a go part one let's give
this a try and see how it differs number
one from obviously compound interest but
number two from a regular kind of
superannuation where you just put in the
same amount every time now in past
questions they will say yeah let like a
of n is equal to something but we don't
have any a of n here so I need to define
one I'm going to say let a and dollars
what would you like to call that
obviously have something do tiny right
what would you like to define in to be
yeah I would say now I've got two
choices yeah this say it's the number of
months but to be a little more specific
I'm going to say rainy in the month that
is okay the reason why is because you
can see the timing in the month matters
right at the start of each subsequent
month that's when the deposit goes in
and then at the end in every month the
interest gets applied right one and then
the next and the order of significantly
matters right so we need to watch that
let's do this then let a and B be amount
and please let's skip this step even
though it's like it's not maths or
actually it is because it will define
the equations in the right row second
behemoth at the end of the nth month
okay so if I say well where do I begin
what is the first thing two things
happen every month there is one a
deposit and number two is going to be
the interest calculation yes okay so I
start with this first deposit I actually
don't exactly what it is it's 500
there's the first thing that happens and
then the second thing is an interest
calculation is that okay so what am I
gonna do with this paper
yeah in fact I'm really going to do this
like for the first the first deposit
compound it just just applies to it just
like you right so it's one point zero is
zero three mark the extra percentage
straight the extra zero and that's one
place that's a sorry subscribe to okay
okay there you go there's the first
amount I've done the deposit I've done
interest that's it okay next thing right
the next month again the same two things
happen so I start with this right that's
what I had before and then I get an
extra deposit now what is the size if
that was it
yeah I said it's gonna be 500 but it's
gonna be a big big up right so I'm gonna
write that as 500 and then busy extra 1%
so I'm gonna get one point over 1 so
there's the first thing that happened
for deposit now one yeah the entire
thing note that the entire thing gets
the interest calculation so that whole
thing gets a one point zero zero three
added on so I don't want to clarify that
get through the wait so I told you not
to be lonesome about 500 120 years
okay so it says so if I just want to
make a series out of the deposits only
and forgetting about the rest of you can
write the first of us is 500 the next
deposit is 1% more than that deposit so
as 500 then it's 500 times 101 percent
then it's that times made 1% it's that
times 101 percent correct so it's one
percent more than the previous deposit
and not the whole amount that's in the
account because he would run out of
money very fast and did that okay so now
that I've got that right you notice I've
done this already by the way I always
include like save it as a one don't just
put like numbers in there say what they
come from okay so now I'm gonna
substitute to you because that's that's
should be giving me this right explain
why the balance that you cut at the end
of the second month is that so I should
be getting from there to there does that
make sense
let's see what happens so I've got
okay please don't skip any of these
steps the maths is simple like it's
simple so therefore your detected to
demonstrate everything to explain why
you're doing this so this is my
explanation so far and I'm almost there
you can see I'm pretty much there I just
need to multiply through and out pops
this right so that initial deposit bring
it with me like don't just write down
the numbers the first deposit has been
in there for two months so that's why
it's got two interests calculations
applied to it you see that that's what
that means and then here is the second
months deposit it's like it started off
bigger and also it had one lot of
interest applied to it
yep cool so far so good then they throw
you right in deep part to final it down
to the account at the end of the 60th
60th month so clearly and I won't have
to do a one eighty two eighty three all
the way I'm gonna have to generalize to
get to the 60th correct to the nearest
dollar